hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that doesn't ask you to sit
through three hours of content with no
bathroom break I mean don't get me wrong
you are more than welcome Nate
encouraged to watch three straight hours
of content on this channel YouTube would
love me for it and I would be rewarded
with riches beyond compare
but unlike endgame if you need to run to
the most in-demand throne in the
universe with me you get the bonus of
letting my soothing voice accompany you
on your phone well you're sitting there
doing whatever it is that you're doing
so there was a lot to unpack in Avengers
endgame and while I have plenty of
thoughts on future theories most of them
involved time travel or 21 movie deep
lore or figuring out what size clothes
The Hulk banner combo is wearing because
the sweaters go way beyond husky where's
he getting those things
half the population was snapped out of
existence there are not enough people
around to do bespoke tailoring of your
monstrous new figure so today I wanted
to start off with something a bit more
basic something a bit more fundamental
to the entire premise of this movie the
fact that it's ridiculous
yeren me write the entire idea of this
movie happening in the first place seems
impossible to me and no I'm not talking
about time travel I'm not talking about
Doctor Strange portal battles or Tony
Stark inventing time travel in less than
five minutes no I'm not talking about
his miraculous rescue from the middle of
space or Thor becoming existential
crisis Santa I'm talking about this
moment right here a rat walking across a
keyboard and setting ant-man free when I
was sitting there in the theater and I
saw this scene I'm like are you kidding
me
you expect me to believe this I don't
care how much you love the movie this of
all things is how Scott Lang is getting
out of the quantum realm I mean I am on
board with everything else in this movie
Marvel I can't get enough of character
reunions a visit to the Thanos
retirement home beautiful poetic main
character deaths heartbreaking but
you're telling me that all of that
everything that we see in the entirety
of endgame is based on a random
stepping on a random button in some
storage parking garage and I'm in no way
exaggerating here this isn't me trying
to make this sound more important than
it is to hype up this episode don't
forget this single rat button press is
the only thing that leads to the return
of Scott Lang aka ant-man for those of
you who forgot he's been hanging out in
the quantum realm an interdimensional
kind of space-time soup for over five
years leading up to this movie this rat
tripping over itself on this car is the
only reason he's rescued from time-space
exile which in turn is the only reason
that he introduces the idea of time
travel as a possible solution to the
snappin egg which is the only reason
Tony Stark and the rest of the Avengers
get involved in the first place the only
reason he and Captain America bury the
hatchet the only reason they succeed in
travelling back in time retrieving the
stones and saving the universe and
everyone who has snapped away it
literally starts here and only here you
have got to be kidding me
this entire 22 movie franchise the epic
conclusion to over a decade's worth of
movie ultimately hinges on an act of
rodent randomness saving half of the
living universe so rather than be
annoyed by this which honestly was what
I was when I left the theater after
endgame I decided to put my theory where
my mouth was and figure out whether this
was even remotely possible in the real
world what are the odds of that rat
stepping on that panel and when you stop
and think about it it shouldn't seem
like that weird of a thing to do I say
to myself trying to justify my own
self-imposed insanity but seriously this
entire movie is predicated on the whole
idea of the Avengers having one chance
in 14 million to be Thanos this entire
franchise is just one massive statistics
puzzle endgame is all about that one
chance and 14 million to win when the
odds are definitely not in the hero's
favor but I'm telling you going into
this theory that I don't think those
odds have much to do with time travel
and Infinity stones and intergalactic
battles and Tony Stark taking the
Infinity stones for himself no I think
that 99.9% of those universes are all
just wasted trying to get a single rat
to step on an effing button but to be
sure let's find out shall we
the first question is why are you not
subscribed to this channel we cover
ridiculous questions like this all the
time secondly though and more
the point how in the world do you
calculate the odds of something like
this
this is like the world's worst google
interview question and to be fair as we
go through this we need to make a couple
of assumptions that'll allow us to
actually reach some conclusions and have
a hope of finishing this episode in less
than twenty minutes so let's start with
the rats
there are obviously tons in a city like
San Francisco where Scott Lang lives but
we'll need to estimate how many there
are in the area around his van how much
ground they can cover and also the odds
that one would step in a particular spot
over the course of five years because
remember that's how long scott waits to
be rescued before the magic moment
happens and this entire plot of the
movie can get underway luckily for Scott
and the rest of the universe San
Francisco happens to be completely
overrun with rats this is not a joke in
2018 there were news reports that people
had to wait weeks for an exterminator
because there were so many rats and not
enough people to wipe them all out in
fact San Francisco is the fourth most
rat infested city America I'm assuming
number one is Washington DC boom ching
political humor ladies and gentlemen get
dunked on politicians in New York 2014
survey estimated that there are about
1/4 of the number of rats in New York as
there are people so applying this ratio
to San Francisco with about 900,000
residents we get 225,000 rats which is
just a heck of a lot of rats if you live
in a big city you just don't think too
much about how many rats you share your
block or your apartment building with
right now the maximum range a rat is
willing to travel from its nest is 50 to
150 meters so we're gonna take average
here at a hundred meters it's bigger
than the length of an entire football
field in every direction translates to
thirty one thousand four hundred and
fifteen point nine square meters when
you PI R squared it out that is a huge
amount of ground to cover when we want
the rat to just step on a button that's
like an inch square or about 6.25 square
centimeters San Francisco proper is
forty six point eight seven square miles
or 121.4 swear kilometers 225,000 rats
each technically able to cover thirty
one thousand four hundred fifteen point
nine square meters in their territory
means
they're technically able to cover over
seven million square meters and as a
result could be covering the entire open
space of San Francisco hundreds of times
over this is especially true when you
consider that they have to stick mostly
to the outdoors sewers and yes storage
facilities and garages rat ground zero
is likely to be right in the area that
ant-man was last seen in ant-man and
wasp that last scene where we see dr.
Pym send ant-man into the quantum realm
takes place here with the Coit Tower to
the right and the Transamerica building
due south this gives us a pretty much
hundred percent likelihood that Scott
Lang's car actually falls within the
territory of plenty of rats which I
already thought was a stretch when I
started this theory but I was wrong
there are a lot more rats in San
Francisco than I thought okay
saying that Scott's car falls into the
territory of a few rats doesn't
guarantee that one will ever step on a
very small button realistically though
we're not just dealing with one rat you
see unlike you tubers rats aren't loners
they enjoy things like socializing and
sharing they live in groups rat colonies
have a population of up to 100 rats in
fact so if this van is in the range of
some rats it's actually gonna be in the
range of a lot of rats but remember that
at the end of infinity war half of all
living beings in the universe got
snapped away that means that at the
beginning of the five years we're
dealing with 50 ish rats in Scott Lang's
area so how much ground are these 50
rats covering well it actually depends
on how fast they're going once we know
that we'll be able to know how many
places they could randomly step in the
course of a typical rat day and then
statistically how long it would take
them to step on this one button if we
can estimate an average walking speed of
3 point 5 centimeters per second for
rats rats can actually move a lot faster
than that because their gate or if
they're walking slash running speed can
range from three point five to eight
point five centimeters per second
depending on how exciting that
four-year-old Twinkie on the other side
of the dumpster is looking but we're
interested in what it's average speed
would be across its entire day also
knowing that a rats stance or the
distance between its feet is about half
an inch wide lets us take the walking
speed the linear distance covered per
unit time to the area that the rat is
physically covering during that time
think of the rat as a moving rectangle
that's trying to fill in all the spaces
of this
circle that is its territory right so
knowing its walking speed and knowing
its average foot placement we're able to
calculate how much area it's covering
her unit of time and that translates to
four point four four square centimeters
per second so the question now is how
long is a rat actually out there
wandering around searching for food
versus sleeping or doing stuff around
the nest like learning cool rat trick
sir I don't know giving birth to the
next generation
well rats tend to be nocturnal which
means that they're usually taking the
night shift and scrounging around for
food for about eight hours a day from
9:00 p.m. to 5:00 a.m. no weekends off
so calculating out how long they search
and the area that they're covering per
second on any given single rat day a rat
would cover twelve point eight square
meters that's a tiny fraction of it's
thirty one thousand four hundred and
fifteen point nine square meter
territory in total and the rat has a
teeny tiny chance of finding Scott's
button on any given day to be exact that
rat would have a point zero four zero
seven percent chance to be clear that is
not four percent that is point zero four
percent let me pull out my doctor
strange looking into the future effects
that is one in two thousand four hundred
and fifty four if we give this rat the
ultimate benefit of the doubt that we
can and say that he never goes to the
same place twice in his lifetime which
isn't entirely realistic but hey just
for the purposes of a thought experiment
it would take him or her two thousand
four hundred fifty four days to
completely cover the entire search area
that is six years eight months and
twenty one days of constant rats
searching never covering the same area
twice now I feel okay about this
assumption because it's kind of like a
big average realistically if the van was
close to the rat's nest well this button
would actually have an enormous
likelihood of getting hit early on if
it's on the edge of a rat's territory on
the other hand well the odds become
incredibly low so by spreading out the
area that the rats walking we know we're
not accurately representing real traffic
patterns but instead we're averaging
things out based on the fact that we
have no idea where the rat is actually
starting from so all you but actually
people take it easy trying to take as
much into account as possible no I'm not
taking into account that the van is
elevated and he's got to climb up there
and all that yeah I get it we're talking
pure
so if the rat searches the whole area of
its territory and the very last bit of
it happens to be the button that he's
walking over that fries Scott it would
take almost seven years to lot but it's
nowhere close to what I was actually
expecting I was expecting this beyond
the probability of like never in order
for the rat to come across Scott's
button in five years like movie shows he
would need to hit that button within the
first 1825 days based on our
calculations there's actually an
unbelievable fifty four point seven
percent chance that it could do that I
can't believe I'm saying it but it's
better than a coin cost that a single
rat would step on a button that fries a
guy from the quantum realm but that's
not all if we keep factoring things in
can actually do a lot better remember
Scott is not just counting on one rat
he's counting on 50 covering the same
territory because they share the same
nest so if we rerun our calculations
based on the idea that 50 rats or each
searching independently our five-year
search actually gets a lot more
optimistic if a single rats odds of
randomly freeing Scott are a little over
50% the odds a 1 of 50 rats rambling
stumbling into freeing Scott are a
staggering 99.9999 7% I suppose you
could say that the rats is inevitable
even if we are less optimistic about the
future of the rat population and decide
the Thanos snap the number used in our
previous estimate and do the
calculations based on a smaller number
of rats like 10 rats traveling at their
slowest speeds and only hitting this
spot once in their lifetimes odds of him
getting found in 5 years is still 99.94%
and that is with us repeatedly taking
the low estimates on every step of this
process dr. strange might have seen 14
million 605 futures and only one path to
victory but out of those 14 million 605
futures fourteen million six hundred and
one of those futures involves Scott
being freed by a rat and only four of
them with Scott trapped forever in the
quantum realm or just freed by a hippie
looking for a new van instead of a rat I
mean this is San Francisco we're talking
about so
at the end of the day the odds might not
have been on the side of the Avengers
but they were certainly on the side of
ant-man but hey that's just a theory a
film theory and looking at the Avengers
lineup you know what's missing I mean
we've got ourselves err oh man Thunder
God
tiny man large man living tree and mr.
America 2.0 it seems like he got most of
your bases covered I don't know my
friends you've got yourself one key
weakness with the team as it's currently
set up
you're missing a hacker I mean we just
lost our tech genius and that sentient
lazer computer guide died shortly before
that because here's the thing my friends
without the proper online protection all
the super strength in the world isn't
gonna help and your identity gets stolen
and your bank account gets cleaned out
luckily you don't need to be on
earth-616 to find an appropriate hero he
already exists here in this universe via
our sponsor for today's episode Nord VPN
Nord is a superhero in lots of different
ways Nord uses thousands of super fast
servers across 60 countries all working
to circumvent firewalls encrypt your
data usage and ultimately keep your
activity invisible online regardless of
whether you're using a tablet a phone or
a computer if you torrent or do any sort
of peer-to-peer sharing a VPN is a must
in order to de-identify your IP address
Nord is basically like Aquaman except
instead of fish it's able to summon the
power of international servers to rescue
your data but Nord is also no longer
just about online protection with the
passing of article 13 over in Europe a
VPN is actually going to become more
important than ever before because a VPN
will help you get around region specific
restrictions so you can still watch
content like this show content that uses
other people's IP and fair you see ways
even if the governments of their
respective regions don't necessarily see
it that way thanks to Nord VPN a few
clicks and your internet connection
suddenly looks like it's in a completely
different part of the world a part of
the world that's not subject to such
strict rules around IP usage one
subscription to Nord gets you coverage
across six different devices with
unlimited bandwidth so go to Nord VPN
comm
film theory right now and get yourself
75% off a three-year subscription and
then once you're checking out you can
use the code film theory again and get
yet another month completely free it's
an investment in yourself it's an
investment in your online security and
also your supportive Nord is an
investment in us because it means that
they still want to partner with us which
helps us cover the bills so thank you so
much and thank you to Nord for their
continued support now if you'll excuse
me I have a few more thoughts an end
game I got to start scripting out cuz
like I said this movie had a lot to
cover but more on that next episode